the rapping and
and with the comedy and and inventing
planking
you invented planking yeah well
playing i didn't call it planking but
one of the early bits on my show i would
go and i would just lie down on my face
until people came and called an
ambulance
you know and then you know years later
everyone was lying down on their face
and and i was credited with that but uh
but we didn't really call it planking
but but yeah you know i mean you know
this it's like
we we kind of like uh you know what i
find interesting about the world today
is everybody's kind of doing what we did
back when we were younger you know
so many people like people are kind of
able to go out and kind of create their
own thing
and do their own thing and and uh that
was sort of so much
sort of more of an obscure idea back in
the day where you could actually just go
make your own
your own content as they call it content
so um i mean it's uh
it's it's it's sort of weird to think
that we're still doing this [ __ ] you
know
right certainly you know i sometimes
kind of kind of find it amazing because
you know i'm turning 50 this year and uh
you know i'm trying to do different
things now but it's still kind of all
rooted in the same thing you know i'm
really enjoying the video i'm doing
enjoying doing photography
i've got you know my new cameras my
drone i'm going out there shooting all
these
rad shots you know it's your birthday in
august
what's that is your birthday in august
july 30th i just like these are pretty
close pretty close to yeah oh yeah
guess what i have the number 30 ranked
hot sauce on
all of amazon it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon
and buy stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
yeah yeah
dude